- Hey everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
into Market Takes.
We are starting a little bit late today.
Had to get over some
technical difficulties.
I appreciate y'all being patient with me.
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me.
I appreciate that, I
never forget about it.
So, apologies for our late
start, but let's jump into it.
This week we have a big week.
Earning season has already
kicked into full swing
so I'm gonna be telling you about that.
But also the three most important things
that you need to be
watching out for this week.
Not all of 'em are Earnings reports,
but some of them are.
Listen, we've got the retail sales report
that's coming out tomorrow.
Hope you'll be with us right here
at 10:00am on Market Takes.
We'll be breaking that down.
That comes out tomorrow morning.
We also have the leading
economic indicators report
that's coming out on Thursday.
And earning season,
we got kicked off with
the banks last week.
This week we've got
Tesla, United, Netflix,
Johnson and Johnson,
Capital One, Goldman, Sachs,
Bank of America, Morgan
Stanley, and much, much more.
We'll tell you what you need to watch
and what to watch out for
in those Earnings reports.
So, let's start it off talking
to you about retail sales
and what we can expect from the
retail sales report for June
that's coming out a
little later this month.
First things first, wanna
throw up here on your screen
the latest numbers that we've seen
from the retail sales report.
And as you see there,
some of those numbers are going negative.
You see really four the past seven months
we've seen negative reports
on that retail sales number.
So, we have seen over the past
couple months a pick backup
like we saw in January and a
reversal of that early trend.
It seemed like okay, the
trend was just gonna be
negative going forward
but the last couple months
we have seen positive numbers
and economists are predicting
that we will see an increase
of 0.5% month over month.
That would be the biggest
increase we'd seen
since that January number
that we got in February
that you see there, that big pickup.
So, economists are expecting retail sales
to start rising again.
And this chart is illustrating
that we really did break away
from that trend that we had seen of
retail sales being negative,
folks not buying, staying home,
they're clearly coming out
and going shopping again.
As we look inside the report,
it's gonna be interesting though
as retail sales pick back up.
We're gonna have to dig into the details.
So, how hot are the services components,
bars, restaurants, attorneys,
all those things, barbers,
things like that where you're
getting a service performed.
Is that hot?
Because that's what's really picking up
and pushing inflation higher
and that's the fed's
gonna be watching out for.
So, you are wanna watch
out for that as well.
And are they slowing?
Goods prices have been slowing.
We've seen energy, gasoline prices
or as prices at gas stations going down.
So, does that continue?
And what is really gonna be the key?
Is that services component?
June will be the last month
of the second quarter.
So, could have a big impact
on earnings expectations as well.
Next thing I wanna talk about
is the leading economic indicators
or the index of leading
economic indicators.
Let's put a chart right
up here on your screen.
What we've seen from that.
Here's why this is a big deal.
As you see on the right of your screen,
we have been substantially
and significantly negative
and every time that the
leading economic index
has been this low, we've had a recession.
So, you see those light gray
bars there on your chart,
those are recessions and every time
that we get to this
level, we are right now,
when you see the decline,
we have a recession.
And this chart really just again,
illustrates that historical theme
that we have seen over time.
Leading economic indicators
are things like the S&P 500
but also the interest rate,
the tenured treasury
minus the fed funds rate,
credit indexes.
They also look at things
like business surveys,
ISM and S&P 500 or the S&P, excuse me,
global index of service
or purchasing managers,
manufacturers, new orders,
how are the manufacturing
industry doing, things like that.
And those tell us about
the economic indicators.
Those are indicators of what's
going on in the economy.
It's been a long-term
accurate recession indicator
for a long time
and it is strongly pointing
towards recession right now.
Other thing, listen, it's earning season
and what I wanna throw up
here on your screen right now
is what we've seen from
the S&P 500 stock index
and clearly one part of the LEI
that has been moving higher,
especially in recent months.
You see they're really just
the stock market taking off
over the last couple months.
That's a six month chart
going back to March,
I'm sorry, this is a three month chart
just going back there towards March
and you've seen really a big pickup
going on in the stock market
and especially over
the last couple months.
That just illustrating again
the bullish sentiment that we
are seeing from Wall Street
on those investor sides.
But businesses really have
not continued to do that.
So, we need to hear from them this week
in terms of that bullish sentiment.
So, analysts are predicting
that we will have the
biggest Earnings decline
in three years, but they
also predict the S&P 500
will go up another 9% over the next year.
Those two things really don't go together,
especially when the Fed
has interest rates high
like they do right now.
So, what do we got this week?
We've got Tesla.
Listen, Tesla's up 160% so
far this year, year to date.
Is that gonna continue?
Last earnings or last quarter,
the earnings were not so great.
We saw net income down 24%.
And also, Tesla launched
a bit of a price war
in the electric vehicle space.
So, we are going to see just
how that's going for Tesla.
We've also got Netflix
coming out this week.
How did that crackdown
on password sharing go?
You guys have probably heard about that
if you haven't experienced it yourself.
That was supposed to
deliver a lot of new signups
and it's first, you know,
when they first announced
this back at the end of May,
we saw a blog post from Antenna.
It's the service provider
and they chart things like online signups.
They said Netflix got a hundred
thousand daily new signups
on May 26th and 27th.
So, we'll see.
We'll find out in the Earnings
report if that delivered.
You know, there were a
lot of big promises made
for of 1.3 billion in profit, 3.4% growth.
We'll see if they actually
delivered on those.
United Airlines, another
one we will get this week.
The stock really has not ever
recovered from those COVID
or from that big COVID downturn.
Stock has picked back up a little bit
but we're still hovering in there.
How does this season right
now, the summer travel season
is that gonna get united back on track
and are we gonna see data
that they really have gotten back on track
and are able to make money off
of the summer travel season?
How much of those canceled
flights hurt the airline
and are they able to keep
charging these high airfares?
We have seen in the CPI inflation data
that airfare prices have
been down across the board.
So, how does United deal with that?
We heard from Delta last week.
Capital One, Bank of America,
Goldman, and Morgan Stanley
are all out this week.
They're gonna tell us
a lot about the health of the consumer,
but a lot more about businesses
or businesses bullish
as sentiment picking up,
are they making those deals,
mergers and acquisitions,
are they investing, things like that.
We don't know and we're gonna find out,
you know, this week when we
hear from those companies.
Goldman is gonna be big.
Morgan Stanley's also gonna tell us
about those wealthy high net
worth individuals all that.
Capital one and B of A are gonna tell us
a lot about the consumer.
How much are they putting
aside for loan loss provisions
and things like that.
Debit card versus credit card spending.
We know credit card
spending picked up huge
for JP Morgan Chase,
as well as Wells Fargo.
That's what we found out last week.
So, what's going on with
Capital One and Bank of America?
So, we'll find out this week.
So listen, that's gonna do it
for us here on Market Takes.
I appreciate you tuning in.
Be sure and check back with
us tomorrow morning 10:00am.
We will be here unpacking
the retail sales report
tomorrow morning.
So, if you'll stick with us.
And we'll do it again tomorrow morning.
I hope to see you there on Market Takes.